you
mad flavor here [ __ ] a beautiful
Saturday morning November 5th are you
kidding me or what uncle Joey here
getting ready to get the [ __ ] day
started witches cool that's a good
[ __ ] hit I've been up since like
[ __ ] 6:30 had to make a few moves
wash my [ __ ] but I'm back two eggs a
week toast I'm gonna make a protein
shake right now and it's over to get
this [ __ ] day started I got a little
park nasha with my daughter I got to
[ __ ] sock a class with my daughter
I'm gonna shoot over to jiu-jitsu I'm a
smoker more reefer so I'm gonna see some
friends on the smoke some more reefer
and then it's our da vs. L [ __ ] Kukui
tonight [ __ ] I hope you excited
it's one of my favorite cards of the
year but listen what am I in MMA analyst
I don't give a [ __ ] right now it's
reefer time concept
no you carry NZ the Dutch station I got
some [ __ ] brief is a debt today I got
this hard-core OG which gives you [ __ ]
you could look through all this [ __ ]
like that and this tower was a
[ __ ] and let this brittle
yesterday in the Sinai was 90 degrees I
got the sunroof open Sun beaming down on
that [ __ ] bud he's better than
[ __ ] me let's try off this [ __ ]
thing this weed looks [ __ ] nasty
it smells nasty I opened it my [ __ ]
office and my wife you smell it in the
kitchen that's how good this [ __ ]
weed is it smells like rat piss and
[ __ ] god knows what else but that's
the [ __ ] you're looking for in a reefer
you understand if you want to see the
devil you wanna see the devil you wanna
keep smoking that [ __ ] you smoked you
forgot to put a filter on the joint shut
the [ __ ] up [ __ ] uncle joy I don't need
no [ __ ] filters
Diablo way I can feel the heat on my
eyeballs
understatment I'm sitting here in the
Garden of Good and Evil oh my god you
[ __ ] who's better who's better
than me
then I get to deal with you guys on a
regular huh I got [ __ ] family that
fat these [ __ ] got an army we
got family that's more important than a
[ __ ] army what's an army families
will have better we do this for
ourselves cuz we love one another we
help each other one with Donal we pick
each other up you know how we do it we
boys just a but joyful actually I go
hang out with my grandpa you're
absolutely right
sweet four time [ __ ] was watching
since our Latin thing this morning a
movie that was cut 1972 had to cheetah
in New York City with the Fani horses I
was just watching this morning I was
trying to make notes [ __ ] tremendous
I went to see that movie
like [ __ ] nineteen days in a row and
148 to Street with all my dirty little
Puerto Rican friends this and Daniel
Brothers we went in there we'd sneak and
we didn't give a [ __ ] jack this was way
before a refill way before anything is
just we'd have a Spalding ball and a
[ __ ] knife in our pocket but we
didn't give a [ __ ] jack we'd hustle all
day then we play in the [ __ ]
afternoon we shakedown [ __ ] business
owners and sweep their businesses break
their [ __ ] windows that's what kids
are supposed to be doing not they should
do today we all get a trophy that [ __ ]
that's why you're all a bunch of little
[ __ ] half of [ __ ]
I'd say the clock what the [ __ ] have you
done with your life understand the war
already out here right and smoking
reefer get the day plan remember a man
without a plan is not a [ __ ] man
Miche [ __ ]
I've been decided the morning a long
[ __ ] time
but that's what makes your morning
better that's what happening you would
kid your minds were [ __ ] boring as
[ __ ] hey you saw some cartoons let me
tell you some you smoke a bowl and watch
cartoons now it's a life changer I was
watching that letter of avatar this more
than this [ __ ] flying [ __ ] dragons
and leopards yeah I love that [ __ ]
anyway I got no comedy tonight not only
do no [ __ ] Tommy tonight's family
night you understand me it's very
important you know how to [ __ ] break
up get tonight if not you're a dead man
do I know this is 30 [ __ ] no at 30 oh
you wanna do is get the [ __ ] out of the
house but when you become an old man you
see things done while you all see when
you [ __ ] dirty so if you get a chance
to spend time with your family you gotta
do it you gotta put the effort in I know
you'd rather be out jumping up and down
with your Harvey although friends but
when you [ __ ] like gumption you ain't
got a family
are y'all harvey homo friends gonna be
there for you then they're gonna be all
[ __ ] tied up and there you are along
the [ __ ] boat sucks with you you have
a divorce and you [ __ ] think about
why you [ __ ] lost all those things
makes you stronger for the next one you
know everything that kitchen the stomach
makes you [ __ ] stronger that's why
wouldn't you do to as much as I can as I
get choked down every day
I don't give a [ __ ] I got a gun at the
house with a bazooka I'm saying ain't
gonna choke me out of life when you
leave there
you said you know who you can [ __ ]
[ __ ] go [ __ ] up
I have no idea what that's it and that's
that we smoked a bowl of dope
we've got to chitchat like [ __ ]
family and that's the most important
thing remember next Saturday night I'm
at the Foxwoods casino in Connecticut
come on up say hello the fights gonna be
there after which we're just gonna go to
another bar and watch the fight into our
own [ __ ] now fight companion and
beside that that's it that's that
Saturday imma [ __ ] boss little bit
like eight seats you gotta sit next to
some guy that sticks like ten dead
[ __ ] donkeys but besides that you
know I love you [ __ ] have a
good weekend be safe tonight don't let
nobody [ __ ] with you keep your eyes up
and watch that [ __ ] door always know
where you're at the [ __ ] Club watch
that [ __ ] door and you got almost
like a [ __ ]
you get done you start [ __ ] outlaw
[ __ ] and then throw that knife
you always have to have a knife for
start practice and you can always carry
a knife start practicing or you need is
one good [ __ ] throwing you got him in
the shoulder and it gives you a minute
to escape the small details understand
me December 8 see so uncle Joey Diaz his
first bucket special guess what it's
freek they're gonna course you're done
if you sign up today you got it for two
months free see so and the code is Joey
who's better than you [ __ ] and there
you have it you have to smoke it up with
Joey this morning without the chitchat
let you know what's crack-a-lackin' got
the video of this when I can't get it
you'll get it [ __ ] under Africa will
gonna get it to get it
and beside that have a good day you know
I love you to all my heart you're my
family
I don't need no [ __ ] fans if I own
the fans I play a [ __ ] ukulele
I don't know fans or family you're not
family go hang out with somebody else
there's plenty of [ __ ] jerk boats you
can follow another oh he's so good
anyway have a great week on with your
[ __ ] family
I'll see you [ __ ] maybe tonight
we'll do one of these maybe tomorrow
maybe we'll do enough we'll do one
tonight for the Frank companion how's
that you know what there's our [ __ ]
love you stay black
have a great day with your family your
friends you're sucking dick sucking
somebody's [ __ ] that's your
prerogative
I love you have a great day